like i make mistakes all the time i
think what we're talking about here is
principles to strive for if you want a
lasting youtube business if you want to
last in the creator economy continue to
work from home and build ever increasing
impact as well as income from your
youtube content don't sacrifice your
reputation for short term growth
is a book as old as the bible relevant
for the modern business owner and
youtube content creator the answer is
yes and in this episode of the think
media podcast we're going to be learning
three unbreakable youtube tips from the
bible that will work for every creator
to grow their channels and ultimately
make a greater difference in the lives
of people but a huge disclaimer as we
start this this episode is going to be
helpful to you no matter what your
background or beliefs are if you are not
a person of faith um or you wouldn't say
that you're a christian or a bible isn't
a main text that you look at you're
still going to love this episode and i
believe it's worth your time to stick
around and that you'll get some
practical value out of this personally i
am a christian and the bible is my
guidebook for life it's my guidebook for
my business and it's helped me really
achieve what we've achieved at think
media as i follow these principles and
i've picked out three that are really
just valuable for anybody so i want to
encourage you i think this episode will
be amazing whether you're a christian of
a different faith agnostic atheist i
encourage you to stick around and i just
want to say that i appreciate you and
and why the bible though you know i
actually really believe that the bible
is the greatest success book of all time
it is the best selling book of all time
and i've found that the best lessons
whether spiritual or related to business
actually come from scripture the book is
timeless therefore it's timely and it
speaks right into modern situations that
we're going through you know we're going
through a recession right now in america
in turbulent times in the world and the
bible talks about that it talks about
famines and it talks about wars and it
talks about rumors of wars and it talks
about how to respond and how to have
peace and how to take practical
action you know i believe that we were
also created by god on purpose for a
purpose and because we were made in the
image of god we were created to create
so what better book
for content creators than the very word
of
god god is a maker and if we are made in
his image we are makers as well we make
content we build
businesses we architect ideas we have
powerful imaginations and then we can
put in the work to bring those thoughts
into reality as brick by brick we apply
practical principles so as a business
owner and a content creator you're going
to find valuable wisdom and practical
tips that will help you grow your
youtube channel in the pages of the
bible and i want to cover three today on
this podcast episode and here's number
one
stop overthinking and start posting more
videos to youtube now where's that come
from in scripture
ecclesiastes 11 6 says this
plant your seed in the morning and keep
busy all afternoon for you don't know
if profit will come from one activity
or the other
or maybe both
and this verse is so true for youtube
content creators because so often we can
get stuck over thinking what video
should i make next should i post my
video at
three in the afternoon or five o'clock
in the morning should i post five videos
a week three videos a week should i post
10 videos a week the answer
is yes plant your seed in the morning
and keep busy all afternoon you don't
know what if profit will come from one
activity or the other maybe
both and so there's something about
youtube where as much strategy as you
put into it as much research as you put
into it the video that you spend 10
hours editing that you make the perfect
title the best thumbnail and you're like
this is the one that one might fall flat
and get no views and then you like shoot
a video on your phone you just upload
that thing you think it's terrible you
slap a title on there and all of a
sudden that video goes viral and you're
like wow i had no idea and so ultimately
it's this powerful principle that too
many people i've noticed get stuck
overthinking
when it comes to
youtube when really instead
they need to just start taking massive
action and i want to tell you a quick
story
you know
this really became true for me first of
all
over the years when i had a side hustle
and i was working at a day job
i've waited tables i've been a pastor
for a campus of a multi-site church
i've
worked at red robin waiting tables i've
had my own side business doing websites
and video production for clients and
when i've and all through all of those
seasons
i was doing youtube part time and when
i'm doing youtube part time i would
upload videos as much as i could i would
post
10 videos during the summer and one to
two a month during other busier seasons
but i'll never forget 2015
when my life really shifted because i
had three main freelance clients um and
one was paying me 2000 a month the other
was paying me two thousand a month and
one was paying me one thousand a month
that's five grand sixty thousand dollars
a year
my wife sony and i are living in las
vegas no kids at the time two dogs and
we are it's a pretty good income for
living in vegas expenses are uh
pretty good there or cost of living is
lower this is 2015. and i'm probably
making
100 200 300
a month from online income
because i had ranked videos out there
youtube videos posted that are getting
views 24 7 365. i'm making about 60
dollars a month in youtube ad revenue
and 150 or so from amazon affiliates and
if it's the holidays that could go up
almost to a thousand dollars because
people shop on black friday and cyber
monday and as a tech youtuber
at the time talking about cameras
lighting how camera tutorials um that's
where the money was coming from but in
2015
october three freelance clients um they
started to they started to let me go
week after week the first week of
october 2015 a client calls me and said
sean we got to let you go i'm like okay
they're like we hired a full-time person
and um this we gotta you know cut your
contract i go all right you know bummer
but like shoot that's that's cool i
still got two other clients at least and
that was one of the two thousand dollar
clients and then
um i got a call and the second client
called me and said sean
um we need to let you go and i was like
okay what's what's the deal and they're
like yeah we hired somebody we're
shifting some things around we're
reallocating our staff like we're
bringing on an employee we don't need
you as a contractor anymore that was the
second two thousand dollar client
now i'm getting nervous and so then they
get a call uh god is my witness week
three of october 2015 and the one
thousand dollar client calls me and i'm
like i know what this is about you know
what i mean like you're just you're
already so discouraged you're like if
things are already this bad like
murphy's law like it's just gonna
probably get worse and sure enough um
that client let me go as well so in
three weeks i lost three freelance
clients three contracts are sixty
thousand dollars you know a year is what
that 5k a month would map to dries up
completely we are only a few months away
in our savings from being at zero
and so i'm a little bit nervous i'm a
little bit stressed out
and um it was at that moment that i
called a business mentor of mine and
his name's david and i i said david i'm
super worried like i'm losing all my
clients
i don't know what to do
do i call other clients do i pursue
other clients which is reasonable but he
actually told me he goes shawn um you
know
there comes a point in your life when as
an entrepreneur you need to jump off the
cliff
but it sounds like god just kicked you
off the cliff
and now it's your time to fly
and i was like is this david or king
solomon like what what are you speaking
limerick proverbs to me but honestly
that's literally the phone call and i
was like
david uh i appreciate the advice because
he realized that i'd been hustling on
youtube as a side hustle
um and his vantage point was that if i
went all in on youtube
that uh i really had an opportunity
there so
what i did this is october 2015
was after about a week of being just
pretty discouraged and feeling sorry for
myself i started to hustle
and i started to go all in and the
principle from the story
is that i took
massive
action
okay
because what happened was i posted 52
videos in the next two months
between actually this isn't a good idea
but i posted between between three
channels
my
think media channel our video
influencers channel and my personal sean
candle channel i posted 52 videos by
myself now mind you no one's helping me
edit no one's designing thumbnails for
me no one's helping me with titles
nobody's writing descriptions it's all
on me i'm scripting the content reaching
researching the content filming the
content taking the sd card out capturing
the sd card putting it into adobe
premiere editing exporting uploading it
i'm i'm actually making blog posts for
some of them embedding the video in the
blog post putting some text around the
blog post making the title uploading
that on wordpress uploading extra images
there and then even posting on some
social media to promote the videos
coming out it's just me now mind you
because all my freelance clients had
fired me i am now going all in so i'm
spending my time
hustling
plant your seed in the morning and keep
busy all afternoon like i am really
hustling in fact there's a different
version of this ecclesiastes verse it
says sow your seed in the morning and do
not be idle with your hands in the
evening
for you do not know whether morning or
evening planting will succeed whether
this or that or whether both alike will
be good
essentially here's the thing the fact is
i don't know if i should have in
hindsight been posting on three channels
but i didn't know which one was gonna
work i was just doing i was planting
seed everywhere
you know you sometimes could look back
and say well i would have done it
differently but i was just hustling and
i wasn't over thinking i was taking
strategic action
massive strategic action massive messy
action
but i wasn't gonna allow myself to
overthink i was gonna get up and plant
my seed in the morning and hustle in the
afternoon
and as a result my income
from amazon affiliates and from youtube
ad revenue by january
of 2016 so remember i lose my clients in
october i hustle all november all
december i keep hustling into the new
year but my income in just two months
was almost five thousand dollars
from the amazon associates program from
recommending cameras and and lenses and
for people clicking on my affiliate
links
and hundreds of dollars now from youtube
ad revenue and so the five thousand
dollars i had lost from my client work
had been replaced because i put in the
hustle it was strategic i did know what
i was doing i've been husting hustling
five years previous learning about
search engine optimization or intent
based content search based content i
knew my niche i knew who i was trying to
reach it wasn't as clear as it was today
but it was clear enough and so
there it was i was very strategic and
very intentional but i i still
just wasn't overthinking i was just
taking massive
massive action the principle for you
is to punch
over thinking
in the face
and to start taking massive
action and really double down on your
outputs if you got to hustle in the
morning do it if you got to hustle after
work do it if you got to hustle at night
do it you don't know which activities
which videos are going to produce the
results just post them all you're gonna
see i believe incredible things number
two
don't sacrifice your reputation for
short term growth this is a huge
temptation i see for youtube creators
here's the verse proverbs 11 1
and it says this dishonest business
practice is something that yahweh truly
hates but it pleases him when we apply
the right standards of measurement
dishonest business practices
are something that yahweh hates now
yahweh is actually the name of god
that's in hebrew proverbs is in the old
testament and proverbs is this book of
wisdom where we're getting some of these
verses you know written by solomon who
the bible records as the wisest man
wisest king who ever
lived and here's some of the principles
that that speaks to me
don't sacrifice your reputation for
short-term growth here's an example
click bait will hurt your brand in the
long run
what's clickbait we all probably have
seen it someone puts a sensational title
a sensational thumbnail and then the
video doesn't deliver on that promise
now you might actually watch some of our
stuff and say sean don't you sometimes
click bait and it could be misconstrued
because
the truth is just because a title is
like really shocking or a
thumbnail looks like overly sensational
the goal is just if the video actually
delivers what's promised in the title
and the thumbnail well then it's
technically not click bait or that'd be
good click bait but what i'm talking
about is bad click bait
if you look up some definitions of
clickbait it means
deceptive or it means misleading
so listen too many people are just
trying to game the system to get views
if you're trying to trick people you're
just trying to mislead people just to
just to trick the algorithm
and those types of business practices
and youtube practice practices
ultimately hurt your brand in the long
run you know when it comes to
bible secrets for youtube creators i
don't know if there's one that's more
powerful than this don't sacrifice your
reputation for short-term growth there's
so many people who preach tactics about
how you could maybe
do a gimmick or do a trick to get a few
subscribers or get a few views
but that's not going to help you
actually build a brand
where people trust you
in the long term like ultimately that's
the only thing that you're really going
to have
of real value is your brand your
reputation you know there's another
verse in proverbs for point number two
22 verse one it says a good reputation
choose a good reputation
over great riches
i don't think there's a lot of people in
today's world that actually
when given that option would go for that
i think there's a lot of people are like
good reputation
great riches i'm gonna go with the great
riches you know like
whereas
how true is it though that a good
reputation is more valuable than great
riches
now if you really study the bible by the
way it does not
actually prohibit the pursuit
of great riches
it just
teaches actually how to pursue them in
the right way
it's not the love of money that is the
root of all uh it's not
money that's the root of all evil it's
the love of money that's the root of all
evil you study the teachings of jesus
and he wasn't against money he was
against money
being your first priority money
owning you
he was against great riches being your
primary pursuit
there's just countless verses about a
good man leaves an inheritance for his
children's children well how could you
possibly leave an inheritance for your
children's children if you don't have
money in making smart investments if
you're not wise with your finances
so ultimately this is not a prohibition
of one or the other it's saying the
order of which they should be
choose a good reputation over great
riches so to me
don't sacrifice your reputation for
short-term growth
going deeper don't do business practices
with your audience don't betray the
trust of your audience for short-term
growth don't
treat brand relationships and brand deal
relationships that you work with
just trying to get some quick money but
sacrificing your long-term relationship
or the trust with
that brand
if you have customers treat them well if
you have customers and you sell a
product have a refund policy and honor
it well
if you collaborate with people go the
extra mile
treat them well be world class
in your relationships choose a good
reputation first before great
riches the verse goes on it says being
held in high esteem is better than
silver or
gold listen silver or gold is also good
especially as a hedge against inflation
right during times of recession
uh but ultimately having high esteem and
and i share this because you know our
mission at think media is to double the
creator economy
we want to help 10 000 purpose-driven
people and beyond create a full-time
living doing what they love while making
a difference in the world with youtube
and online video and to experience that
success without losing their soul
we are way more interested in you
building a real practical long-term
solid business
rather than just experiencing a quick 15
minutes of fame
and there's too many people in the
crater economy in my opinion that again
i think sacrifice their reputation for
short-term
growth so practically
i just encourage you to create content
with a clear conscience now i don't want
this information
or these principles to also sound
preachy at all because listen
this is coming out of my mistakes
like there's been videos i've made in
the early days of think media where i
was working with a company called fame
bit and it was like a marketplace where
you could do different brand deals and i
just remember
i the idea that a brand would pay me
and and and ultimately uh give me a
product for free and pay me some money
and then i would make a video about it
the fact i just started to apply for
different products and i got approved
for some and then i had to follow
through on making the videos
and i mean it wasn't unethical or
anything that i did but i was just like
getting these brand deals for products
that i really hadn't tested and i really
hadn't put the time in and i was uh i
was at in the moment thinking about
short-term money or just short-term and
and here's the thing it was partly based
on survival because in the early days
i'm like i'm just hoping to make it as a
solo creator but knowing that that was
now a mistake and ultimately thinking
long term that's not the repute that's
not the brand i want to build i want the
reputation of think media to be like if
sean
recommends a camera
like he's going to tell me his real
honest truth about it if sean works with
a brand
he's going to
be vulnerable and he won't even do a
brand deal
that he doesn't believe in like that's
one of the things i coach our team now
is they're thinking about brand deals
i'm like listen
it's not just how much money can we get
it's
do we believe in the product do we
believe the product will be good for our
audience can we stand behind it would we
stand behind it anyways
and then what are the terms of the deal
good reputation first silver and gold
second
and so we do our best at it
and have i made mistakes in trying as
we've grown our brand when it comes to
customers sure have i made mistakes when
it comes to dealing with other
collaborators or you know just other
influencers that i've worked with or
people have run it to events of course
like i make mistakes all the time i
think what we're talking about here is
principles to strive for if you want a
lasting youtube business if you want to
last in the creator economy continue to
work from home and build ever increasing
impact as well as income from your
youtube content don't sacrifice your
reputation for short-term
growth
well i hope that you are enjoying
today's conversation and i wanted to let
you know that if you want to go deeper
with us here at think media one of the
best ways to do that to further your
online education is to take one of our
free on-demand classes you can go to
thinkmasterclass.com
where we do a one hour free deep dive
class into what's working on youtube
right now and how you can gain
subscribers and views and income from
your youtube channel we have several
different options for you but the latest
video for you to watch is at
thinkmasterclass.com this video is not
available anywhere on youtube this is
only exclusively for our think media
community who are ready to go deeper
with us at the end of that class we
share with you an opportunity to become
one of our members inside of this
movement of content creators making a
difference in the world so go to
thinkmasterclass.com right now to get
signed up for your free one hour youtube
on-demand class now let's get back into
today's featured content
ultimately create content with a clear
conscience in the new testament hebrews
13 18 says
keep praying for us that we may continue
to live with a clear conscience
for we desire to live honorably
in all that we do
the author of the book of hebrews is
uncertain some people think it's the
apostle paul and that could be likely
whoever was writing this letter
was ultimately
saying these powerful truths pray that
we can be able to continue to live with
a clear conscience just doing what you
know to be right in your your whole your
heart just knowing doing what you know
to be right like just being yourself be
authentic be true to you
don't try to be somebody else just say
what you mean and do your best to live
with a clear conscience and to live
honorably to stay world class to be a
person of your word listen
the level of accusation
especially at the level i'm at that will
still come to you that would
question your reputation question your
integrity accuse you of click bait
accuse you of all this other stuff
that's that's
that's not to put myself on a pedestal
you don't see one leader who didn't have
criticism you don't see one biblical
figure including jesus who didn't have
criticism now if he is the perfect
sinless man
and the god man
and not only did people criticize him
but they eventually killed him and
crucified him
then
you're going to probably be accused of
things and people are going to
misinterpret your actions
and they may even think
that your reputation is not strong
they'll accuse you of things but here's
what i've learned over time
man the truth comes out
over time it's just a matter of just
staying in integrity staying world class
staying honorable continuing to live
with a clear conscience don't worry
about the negative comments and someone
that's here or there with an opinion
the truth in the long term comes out you
get into enough circles someone might
say you're in a circle in an event oh
man i saw that sean cannell guy can't
believe it and someone in that circle
probably be like i know actually he's a
world-class dude like i know him i know
him personally you know what i mean
that's my hope like and that's the kind
of thing that i hear like you just
eventually the truth will come out
doesn't matter if somebody makes a hit
piece youtube video about you
like anybody of any size eventually is
going to have some kind of hit piece
notice any book you write and put on
amazon it might have ten thousand
positive reviews there's gonna be a
hundred negative reviews so it's not
like you could ever have a reputation
that nobody accuses you of anything
that's not what this is saying it's
simply saying
don't sacrifice your reputation for
short-term growth let's land the plane
on number three
and then i've got kind of an outro
a couple of book recommendations one of
which is the bible and our comment of
the day and all of that good stuff let's
hit number three slow and steady growth
is better than 15 minutes of fame here's
the verse proverbs 13 11 wealth gained
hastily
will dwindle but whoever gathers little
by little will
increase it
man this is a powerful verse for youtube
creators
because there's something about
growing little by little see in a world
where everybody wants to go viral and by
the way that opportunity is
before us right now you have the chance
to go viral
if we go back to number one you just
plant in the morning and at night you
don't know which one is going to produce
fruit maybe both
your chances of going viral go up the
more videos you post
and the more you commit to getting one
percent better with every upload but
here's why i love this
is there something powerful about not
worrying about going viral as much and
just being consistent and growing little
by little
slow and steady growth is better than 15
minutes
of fame
and what i've learned is that it's
really also not just about growing a
youtube channel but it's about the
transformation you will experience as a
leader
as a person
as a creator and as a business owner
in the process
by stepping out and starting a youtube
channel it will change you it will force
you to learn new skills you'll learn to
communicate better you'll be challenged
as a someone to learn marketing and how
to write powerful titles and how to
design thumbnails and come up with video
ideas and concepts that are
attention-grabbing and that add value
but also stand out in the midst of the
noise you'll have to
learn discipline especially in the side
hustle season because you got family and
kids in school and all this other stuff
going on so you gotta really figure out
how to be more disciplined and manage
your time
and so
little by little you'll find yourself
getting stronger little by little
you'll find yourself getting bitter uh
better and
another verse in proverbs that speaks to
this is 2021 and it says an inheritance
gained too early in night life will not
be blessed in the end
so slow and steady growth is better than
15 minutes of fame i propose to you
that maybe you don't want to go viral
i might actually what if what if it
actually could be better for you
and your soul
to not go viral for a while to not have
explosive growth for a while why because
an inheritance gained too early in life
will not be blessed in the end
i am concerned i'm kind of
i feel like an old guy in the crater
economy now you know i'm coming up on my
39th birthday
i started on youtube in 2007
with a video from my local church
that was two years after youtube started
and now that's 15 years on youtube but
it's giving me a unique perspective
a lot of the ogs on the platform they're
not here anymore
i've seen
countless
family vloggers
get divorced blow up their marriages i
mean and they were preaching family
and i'm not coming from a judgmental
standpoint i'm coming from an
observational standpoint
i've seen many
young creators get a lot of money get a
lot of celebrity get a lot of cash get a
lot of notoriety
and get into a lot of controversy
why because an inheritance gained too
early in life will not be blessed in the
end
i'm all for rapid growth i'm not trying
to suggest that it wouldn't be cool for
you to
get massive explosive growth overnight
but there's something about timeless
wisdom from the bible that suggests
that slow and steady growth is better
than 15 minutes
of fame
i know that even for me
and you want to talk about
some of the hardest seasons of my life
and and being really vulnerable with you
here on the podcast
like i am a committed christian and i
and
that means that if i believe the bible
should be my guidebook for life and
and over the last couple years a few
years back though during the rise of the
fame of think media
you know think media starts and there
was all other kind of things happening
in our life challenges with my wife's
health challenges with a former church i
worked at
and as i'm transitioning into full-time
freelance work eventually full-time
entrepreneurship
and
as i'm hanging out in different circles
as i'm also finding that my influence on
youtube is putting me around all types
of different influences
i actually
one started to drink too much and drink
a lot like there'd be a time when i
would maybe be drinking maybe one or two
beers a night which again by the way
you're listening to this like
that's actually
not necessarily too bad i mean i'm not
getting drunk
but
i
was sometimes doing that for a hundred
days in a row there might have been like
not a day goes by when i wasn't drinking
you know you start to research that even
look at just medical professionals
that's not a good idea like that's
that's not good for you and the truth is
there were times though when i was
drinking a lot more than two drinks
and i was drinking too much
and again this doesn't come from
judgment this is coming from this that's
that's not what the bible teaches so i'm
talking about my personal convictions
now and and the standard i'm trying to
hold myself to
and ultimately i'm now trying to numb
the pain because
and the pressure because we're hiring a
team i think media is growing
and as if that's not enough i start to
get into weed and i get to a place where
i'm spending 200 to 300 a week
on marijuana
and
you know it's probably a conversation
for another time and i certainly
you know let me know if you'd love to
hear more about this and and we can go
deeper into some of this content in the
comments if this is meaningful to you or
if you're listening on audio leave
something in the reviews but here's the
point
now sometimes i'm drinking and smoking
weed
vaping whatever you know edibles
and i'm trying to i'm trying to deal
with the pressure i'm trying to numb the
pain i'm slipping into an addictive
cycle i'm the way i'm processing the
stress the way i'm avoiding the pressure
or criticism and just feeling all of
that stuff that's happening listen i see
this happen with a lot of creators
pewdiepie opened up he's like man i was
drinking too much like
i can't even imagine what does he have a
hundred million subscribers listen an
inheritance gain too early in life won't
be blessed in the end and i'm grateful
that i
was as grounded uh as i even was during
those seasons
you know
to to make it through and since then by
the way
this is a few years back but i've
actually given up drinking entirely and
i'm no longer uh consuming weed besides
cbd products which is uh
whatever non-uh non-mind altering but
ultimately
i think a really powerful health benefit
here's the point
um little by little man slow and steady
is better than 15 minutes of fame
there's something about 15 minutes of
fame where i've got a lot of empathy for
all of a sudden
i don't know if we were wired for all
the praise and criticism that can come
from going viral i don't know if we were
wired for all the pressure
and and our character has to get
stronger and sometimes that is only
possible by slow growth not by growing
too fast see i don't want
think media to
in my youtube channel or i don't even
want my charisma or my ability to grow
on youtube to outpace my character
and so i've made decisions to be more
grounded get better friends in my life
more people around my life and find ways
to process stress you know i heard alex
hermozy at one point he was saying just
to get back to a baseline after a day of
stressful work he had to drink
half a bottle of hard alcohol and he
gave up drinking as well what was the
point it's just real stress
forget like the any kind of ethical
moral side of it like
the the emotional side is you got to
build your inner game your mind game you
got to really build your your character
and and healthy ways of processing
stress
because slow and steady growth is better
than 15 minutes
of
fame and
if i want to help you grow wealth
quickly i believe we're living in an era
where you could grow it faster than our
parents could and that's an incredible
blessing because of the crater economy
but maybe if we weren't so much in a
rush
to gain wealth hastily but we were more
intentional about gathering it little by
little over time
saving investing
not trying to just look at the headlines
of the elon musks and the jeff bezos of
the world and and you probably don't
even really aspire like that but you
know what i mean like those are just the
unicorn stories what about the millions
of other entrepreneurs that are not
living that story it's not just mr beast
what about the millions of other
creators who are are doing you know 32k
a year 58 000 a year 62 000 a year and
then not putting yourself down for being
there thinking like you need to go
somewhere else just be disciplined with
your finances suck money away into
retirement and invest in real estate and
little by little
you'll have
life-changing wealth
without getting famous
and so anyways slow and steady growth is
better than 15 minutes of fame as we
land the plane
i want to recommend some resources and
and truly i'm curious
would you like more of these i mean i
got
probably a hundred uh and so this is
just three but i've been studying the
bible intensely for
years and i continue to do so and
commentaries around it i was also
in pastoral ministry for
many years as well and so it's it's a
book i'm passionate about but if not
then then no worries but if let me know
in the comments if you watch the think
media podcast on youtube or leave us a
review and let me know what you thought
about this episode but
i want to share
another verse with you
in joshua 1 verses 7 and 8 and it says
this be strong and very courageous be
careful to obey
all the law my servant moses gave you do
not turn from it to the right or to the
left that you may be successful wherever
you go keep this book of the law always
on your lips meditate on it day and
night so that you may be careful to do
everything written in it then you will
be prosperous and successful
and so i just want to encourage you if
you've enjoyed this episode maybe
you uh are a bible believer but it's
been a while since you've been um in
your bible i encourage you man dive in
like like really
maybe uh go on a year-long bible reading
plan and of course uh i'm not even
trying to say in this episode sean
you're using the bible for but for
business success
i know that's not its primary purpose
but it is applicable to business success
it's applicable to every area of life
and wouldn't you want me to recommend
the bible over
the latest self-help business book
which i'm into those as well
i just think that the bible is the
greatest and the
lens through which all other material
should be
interpreted and evaluated
and so here's my encouragement if you
are
into the bible
dust it off man dive in why
because
if you will
talk about it
and if you will meditate on it that just
means if you think about it you think
about
the kind of content we've been talking
about in this episode and you're careful
to do what it says
then you will be prosperous and
successful
for any kind of critics
about
the prosperity oh is this the prosperity
gospel no there's there's only one
gospel that's the gospel of salvation
through jesus christ christ's death
burial and resurrection there's no such
thing as the prosperity gospel i know
here we go this is a whole new level of
of uh controversy on the think media
podcast
all i know is this is what the book says
man joshua 1 verse 8 you will be
prosperous
and successful but and by the way this
is not this isn't actually really
spiritual it's not saying like
god will make you prosperous and
successful it doesn't say the holy
spirit will magically make money appear
appear
it says
you will another version another uh
translation says you will make your way
prosperous and successful what does that
mean
you will take action
you will approach your business your
youtube channel differently
you will find principles about how you
should conduct yourselves in
relationships
in investing
in
character
in discipline and when you do those
things when you talk about and meditate
on them and you're careful to do them
then you will be prosperous and
successful that's what i've learned
it's not that you'll
encounter magical circumstances we are
all it's going to rain on the just and
the unjust we're going to all encounter
ups and downs in life but we have a tool
called the word of god the bible that
will help us be prosperous and
successful as a result
of
following the principles and so a couple
resources if you haven't downloaded the
youtube
bible app
you virgin bible app it's super cool
it's not only is it free so that's cool
you can download that app on android or
iphone highly recommended the youversion
bible app and then there's also besides
all the
scriptures there to read and study and
wherever you want to start there's some
cool devotionals so if you go into
like the devotionals or reading plans i
think is what they're called you can do
reading plans there's some cool ones for
creatives there's some cool ones for
artists there's some cool ones for
business owners so i recommend looking
at the reading plans in the youversion
bible app it's all free
for
artists creatives business owners and
then anything else i mean right now you
might
you might be single and ready to mingle
so like you might want to look at
relationships
you might be married like of course like
all of that as well but the context of
even this very podcast is business
youtube online business online marketing
and then two other cool resources
there's a really great book um it's
called business secrets from the bible
spiritual success strategies for
financial abundance it's by rabbi daniel
lepin
he's actually an orthodox jew
but man he actually really unpacks the
old testament was written in hebrew he
really unpacks
just just powerful insights
for business and
it's that is a great resource and then
there's a book called 25 biblical laws
of success powerful principles to
transform your career in business by
willian
uh douglas and so
we'll link those up in the show notes as
usual but if anything grab that you
version bible app
who needs to be scrolling on tick talk
for three hours when you could be
scrolling on the bible tick tock's cool
the bible is better it'll probably take
you to a better place and
if you find
and applied to your youtube channel i
really believe it'll help you grow
i want to shout out today the comment of
the day
this is the review of the day from the
think media podcast by the way if you
love this podcast it truly means the
world to heather and i the think media
team and uh borah thydian says this
expand your community with great
guidance i'm relatively new to the scene
in the past six months and these have
been great the passion guidance and
media is very useful this week's episode
explaining looking around and seeing
defeat while in a community of people
who are crushing it
as we make the impossible possible
through opportunity was pulled right
from my head i love it so hey appreciate
your kind words reviewing the podcast
wherever you are if you can rate it
review it put a star on it uh you know
whatever the format
is there
but obviously one of the most meaningful
places that helps get the podcast to
more people is reviewing it on apple
podcasts if you happen to listen to it
there if you just had this episode
shared with you then you could um
please uh subscribe on apple podcast or
wherever you are listening and maybe
there is somebody that'd be interested
in this episode definitely share this
with them
finally um i want to leave you with
galatians 6 9.
i think it's on brand for our episode of
three youtube tips from the bible that
will work for every creator
and uh galatians 6 9 says this it says
let us not become weary in doing good
for at the proper time we will reap a
harvest if we do not
give
up
you know the truth about trying to build
a business trying to build a brand
trying to do anything hard trying to
grow a youtube channel is you're going
to want to give up
you're going to want to throw in the
towel you're going to feel like it's not
growing fast enough or like it's not
growing
and
i love this verse from the new testament
because it says don't grow weary in
doing good at the proper time
we will reap a harvest if we do not give
up there's something about the law of
sowing and reaping where we plant a seed
and we wish
it was a full grown tree by tomorrow
but that's not how the world works
there's something about planting a seed
and continuing to water it even when you
haven't seen
any life break through the soil yet and
then there's something about seeing it
finally sprout that first leaf that
first sign of growth but it's nowhere
near a full grown
prospering
tree or fruit
bush or plant
providing fruit for you that could be
that season of now it's monetized now
it's earning money now it's generating
great things take time and patience
it's amazing that so many people in our
community have had overnight success
they really have they've had rapid
success
but that's really more the exception
than the rule
what we've learned is that it's those
who grow little by little and don't give
up those are the ones that really great
get the great results
so i want to encourage you today
do not become weary in doing good for at
the proper time you will reap a harvest
if you don't give up
[Music]
you